[Music]
Channing Tatum and Jenna Dewan embodying
the picture-perfect image of co-parents
Jenna's been a super mother so like I
want to I want to do my part and be a
super dad the exes were spotted sharing
a hug over the weekend in Los Angeles
out and about with their nine-year-old
daughter Everly putting her family first
and while it's unclear what brought the
former couple together it's not the
first time they've showed a united front
when it comes to their child she's
amazing I'm every day impressed by Earth
last year the two echoed the same
thought about if Everly might follow in
their acting footsteps is your daughter
kind of like getting the bug seeing what
Mom does she's asked me before like
could I have a role in a movie like
she's asked well both you know I I would
say Chan and I are both pretty where you
I don't think we're going to be pushing
acting anytime soon but she's asking but
if it's her passion it's her passion you
know she can be an actress if she wants
to be
um
I think that I feel very uh very adamant
about I don't want her to be an actress
until she's 18.
um
for me I really believe that I want her
to go and have life
and experience life
and not try to because like acting you
really have to kind of get outside of
yourself and really look at like who you
are what you are I just wanted to go be
a person a human and if she's really
interested in acting and and like movies
and stories
she'll find it she'll find it um but not
right now safe to say the two are
definitely on the same page about their
daughter's career path now as for
Channing he says being a father is his
favorite role yet before you have a kid
you either don't want to have a kid or
you do want to have a kid or you don't
know and then it just happens to you and
and like you're never ready for it and
it's always going to teach you and it
still is teaching me she's gonna keep
you in line and uh
I don't know what it's like to have a
have a son but I know what it's like to
have a daughter and it is wild I've
never been creatively challenged more in
my career or in my life than just being
a dad simple day-to-day
[Music]
thank you